for one story more before you leave
because we got to talk about this one
people reports britney just inked a book
deal yes britney spears will publish a
book with simon schuster it's a tell all
all about her life and career what a
life and career that is and the deal was
reportedly worth 15 million dollars uh
i'm already on chapter seven in my head
of that book can you guys wait to read
that i cannot wait it's already it
hasn't been written but it is already in
my amazon cart yeah
yeah it has been read and i would also
like to volunteer my services to write
it to ghostwrite it i've not written a
book but i feel like
how dare you think that britney needs a
ghostwriter
can i just say i hope the first sentence
is this is a story about a girl named
lucky
[Applause]
i really i don't want to make this about
me at all i hate to do that but i did
get to do just throwing this out there a
love scene with her fiance sam in a show
called black monday small plug and i'm
just wondering if i'm going to make the
book you know maybe there'll be a
chapter devoted sure how could they're
not how could they especially with me
ghost writing is
that's right there's your end right
there
well
i just love you guys so much and this
has just been such a dream come true
i mean it's so great it's us and penn
it's from here on out yeah that's the
crew and ross
casey you and i both dived off the desk
in a very similar formation which shows
me we are soul mates meant to be second
to danielle and just thanks to kimbo
my strengths were going everywhere
thank you casey wilson and danielle
schneider hang out with them every week
breakdown wherever you get your podcast
it's one of the best ones out there and
we will be right back
[Music]
you